for people in the north every minute
in bars and pubs counts this weekend
they are already weary of lockdown
restrictions here
and next week it's getting tougher but
at what expense
a non-negotiable financial package from
the chancellor announced this week
is simply not good enough a sign of
unity
from labour leaders of the north it's
their towns and cities
set to face stricter measures we do not
believe that payment will be sufficient
to prevent multiple uh business failure
not just in greater manchester
but across the northwest and the whole
of the north but they're asking for more
to ensure the government keep their
manifesto pledge to level up the country
as others have said there is a very real
concern
and risk that instead of leveling up
covid is going to very significantly
level down and those communities that
were already
deprived already struggling economically
are suffering even greater as a result
of the kobe crisis
liverpool usually a vibrant city is now
home to the highest number of
coronavirus cases
in the country it's why on wednesday it
will feel the full force
of the government's new tier 3
restrictions
the mayor believes almost 1 700 pubs
and bars will be crushed by these new
measures and the knock-on effect
could be devastating oh it's going to be
absolutely devastating for them you know
there's going to be nothing for them to
do
you know i don't know what's gonna
happen to them
you know it's gonna be very um it's
gonna be very difficult financially for
them
but this city needs to suppress the
virus desperately
what's more alarming here than any other
part of the country
is hospital admissions intensive care
doctors from the royal liverpool and
other surrounding hospitals
are telling us they're seeing more and
more patients with kovid 19.
they say the scenes from inside there
are reminiscent
of the height of the pandemic around
about march the hospital was
um was looking after around about 400
covid patients
so our numbers now today being 259 is
getting very close
to that at the moment it's round about
15
of um patients that are in the hospital
that are covered positive
and we know that when that gets to 20
that's when we're really going to start
struggling
to keep doing all the other things that
we know need to keep happening
can you not put that anger anger and
annoyance to one side
and accept what agreements have been put
on the table quickly to save lives
i'm afraid i don't really accept the
premise of your question because i did
accept that at the very beginning
of what i what i said i said there's a
serious situation
um and there are rising cases
um in in the north and we will do what
is needed to protect our residents
the government has said they're
continuing to work closely with local
leaders
on how they can combat the virus
together and we'll keep all financial
support
under review but at the heart of this is
people
millions of them who this weekend will
be grabbing the last opportunity to
socialize
the pressure is being piled on from this
region and whilst for now
this is a northern issue it's inevitable
the same battle for the rest of the
country
is not far off in zama rashid sky news
in liverpool